hello welcome to another episode of not
too deep i'm your host
grace helbig i'm very excited
today we have mike johnson
with us on the podcast you might know
him from hannah brown's season of
the bachelorette um or bachelor in
paradise but he's also
on top of that an author with a new book
coming out called making
the love you want we talk about writing
the book which is incredibly powerful
so go pick it up when it comes out in
october we talk about his process to get
to writing the book we hear
all about the the goofs and the spoofs
on the set of the bachelorette
and uh you know how we got to the place
of even applying it for the job what he
would have done differently and
the surprising celebrity that he gets
mistaken for
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
mike johnson
mike i'm very excited that you're here
thank you for having me grace
of course of course now um for a guest
that i have on the podcast
that have sort of like hybrid kind of
careers i i like to ask them um
what's your deal what's your deal
how would you describe let's say
hypothetically an alien came down and
uh you're introducing yourself to this
alien
how would you describe what it is that
you do and how you exist in the world
a very light question to start off with
by the way no i love it come
hear me right off the bat so i would say
i would sell elon musk because he's like
yes yes i would say bro i'm just a dude
that want to make people happy i wrote a
book that'll teach them how to
find the love that they want i'm an
author first and then you know i did
some pretty cool things trying to find
love and you know
be around the world in the military uh
amazing now this is what i want to kind
of go back to
uh you growing up you are in the
military for how long
i did eight years total i was like four
and a half five years
active duty and i did three and a half
years in the card okay
and how long after the military
did we get to the bachelorette
um i would say from active duty to the
bachelorette was about five years
okay and now my biggest question
obviously and i'm sure you've answered
this a thousand times over
is what happens in that time period that
gets you to the doorstep of the
bachelorette
no one's asked it in that way grace so
okay thank you
uh what happened that time period you
know i fell in love
i got my heart broke i grew up a little
bit became introspective
learned a lot from my mistakes and then
i was like you know
that's right yeah did uh did you apply
for the bachelorette i we were just had
last week uh caitlyn bristol was talking
with us
and we went through like her whole
bachelor bachelorette journey
uh operative awareness journey
how how did your application go did you
apply did producers find you
yeah i wish i could say that they found
your boy you know it was
they just saw me at target or something
but it didn't work out that way
my homeboy actually told me to apply
because
i there was okay so the story is i was
at work i was financial advisor i was at
work one day
and i got annoyed and i kind of just
threw my phone down or whatever
yeah like what's wrong with you bro i'm
like i'm
tired i was like
i'm tired of like not having a girl i
want i want to be in a relationship like
i'm i'm over my ex
i'm over that completely you know i have
you're ready yeah i have girls that hit
me up but like
one thing or another happens i'm like i
just i want the real thing i'm ready for
it and he just started laughing
right he's a good friend like a really
good friend
yeah he's like from a guy's perspective
he was just like bro
you why why why do you want a girlfriend
like he was just laughing his ass off he
couldn't figure out why
and then uh like six months later he
said you should apply for this show
wow so he is the one to blame had you
watched the show before you applied
i have watched one episode before i
applied
and that was in 2017 i had lived at
these apartments downtown san antonio
and i would come home really late
uh from work i was a financial advisor
had a suit on every day and i had like
the little player spot like the really
dope singles
guy spot right yeah a bachelor pad yeah
the bachelor pad
and my my uh neighbor she actually
thought i was an escort
really
yeah just because you had a nice
apartment he said now i asked her i'm
like
why of all the jobs and she's like
well you're always in a suit you're
never
you're never home on the weekends when
you do come home it's really late at
night
and i know how much your apartment costs
and i'm like
what like all the things i'm gonna
escort like that's what your brain goes
to escort
yeah i mean it was either international
spy or escort
and escort for some reason is more
believable wow
what a creative brain your neighbor has
definitely depends but uh so they
invited me over for
the like a bachelor viewing party okay i
didn't know what those were at the time
so i go to the party or whatever you
know chilling with everybody
and my neighbor ashley she said i'm
gonna be the bachelor one day
and like that was the only episode i had
ever watched was just chilling with them
wait she said that you were going to be
the bachelor one day
she did yeah wow what a what a strange
and specific prediction for a friend to
make randomly
but hey here you are now i'm sure some
of your friends said you would be a
host something yeah that i could
potentially make people laugh in some
capacity
um well the thing i love reality
television show
i'm not a major major bachelor
bachelorette person but i
did see your season and you
as a contestant were so striking because
um
one you're wildly charming but two you
also have
such a wonderful [ __ ] meter that
goes off
and calls people out in such a real way
that
i just kept wondering how why is this
real person on a reality
show this person's too real to be
participating in this nonsense
and i appreciated that very very much
and thank you for doing that
um did you know in those moments
i mean because you guys are all
sequestered and it's a experience that's
i'm sure so completely hard to relate to
from anyone yeah but i mean i'm so
fascinated by it because it is like a
social experiment in a way
uh did you know that you were
like reaching a breaking point in those
moments or were you just being yourself
and calling out [ __ ] as you saw it
i'm just calling out the [ __ ] as it
came thank you
as it would come along i'm like bro what
is this like literally they
they cut this out which i'm in
retrospect i'm probably glad they cut it
out
okay i was one of the i was the first
limo
to meet hannah brown and i think i was
the third
person they come out and there was 30 of
us coming out that night
yeah and during the limo entrance
one of the kite one of the guys come in
and i just go
i just i let them have my thoughts like
immediately and we're friends now
but oh god he had said something to the
lines of
hannah you're from the south will you
let me go down south or something like
that
wow and i was like bro like we're here
to find love like if you meet her dad
like
what why would you say that and so i was
still in the depression that
well i still am to this very second
under the impression that
this was a show to find love yeah that's
a very pure and genuine thought
yeah like i'm i'm just a innocent guy
over here thinking like bro i'm trying
to find love
what you're saying before you know so i
appreciate you saying that i have a
[ __ ] meter because
i'm calling like i see it well you know
it's really interesting reality tv
as you probably know and as a fan of it
you can see when people are using a show
for their own means rather than for like
the premise of the show
and so it is really refreshing to know
that you just came in there purely for
the idea of finding love when
a lot of other people are going in for a
wide variety of reasons
i'm sure um that said
what were what were like the what's the
best thing
about the experience and what was uh
i don't want to say worst but a a a
curious part of the experience
uh curious yeah something that sticks
with you but not necessarily for the
best
reasons that's like when uh one of your
friends showed you something that you
think is ugly you're like
yeah you you made a choice with that
shirt
cool yeah a wonderful choice i would say
the best part of the show
or my best time my best experience was
when i got to play rugby with the guys
yeah
that was like super fun and i have so
much more respect for rugby players
your cardio has to be like top-notch
and beyond that was really fun and then
to i mean
it's a bunch of alpha guys when we were
bent up oh
aggression amongst each other so we get
to alleviate that
aggression was really fun um
because i also wonder because you guys
are are you all sharing rooms with each
other
yeah there's about four rooms in the
match that's so nuts to me so yeah you
guys are literally in each other's [ __ ]
all day every day what was the
experience life of like rooming with
everyone while filming with everyone
while
seeing this girl randomly and you're not
sure of what's going on
to me i mean it's like if if i were to
date a girl out here in the real world
i in my back in my brain if we're just
going on the first date
she's obviously having first dates with
someone else that's how i thought of it
when i was on the show i'm like
the only difference is i get to see my
competition
right in comparison to real life i have
no idea what she
what what she's going after so that made
me feel like i had an advantage
hmm that's a really positive way to look
at it yeah that's a very uplifting way
to look at it
i don't i'm just uplifting i don't it's
just who i am but
that's how i looked at her right and
then it was the only weird part was when
i catch one of the guys kissing her and
i'm like
so bro i gotta like i gotta kiss her
yeah i'm sure i think any person that is
you know a normal regular person would
have that reaction in their brain of
being like oh
come on this isn't i okay
here we go okay
like you you can't get upset because you
signed up for it yeah right
but then a part of me is a part of you
whoever will be like
you kiss that like really
like you could have said no to them
you decided to kiss him come on yeah did
you
what was the experience like watching
back this season
because it's one thing to be there and
experience it and then you get to watch
without having any control over how they
portray you as a person
that must have been very nerve-wracking
i must be an alien too because honestly
it wasn't that nerve-wracking to me i
pinky promised you i fell asleep on the
very
so that's great i look good fellas
but that's because i was there i lived
it so it's like
it's like when you know when we're kids
and our parents like record us when
we're children
but like a perfect beautiful camera or
you know 4k capabilities
yeah yeah it's like oh yeah i mean yeah
i do that
that's i don't know that's just how my
brain operates
uh no i think that i think that speaks
to you
knowing that you're a good person so you
don't have to worry about them like
editing you in a certain light that
isn't favorable uh
that's it's nice to know that you have
confidence in like
your decisions and who you are uh
all parts that i acted upon were parts
of who i am
that's yeah that's what you hope i mean
i
obviously reality tv is reality tv it's
very sensationalized but it's always
great to walk away being like yeah
that's exactly who i am
the bachelor nation as a whole though
and everyone that
it comes through that show as
contestants seems to have a really
tight bond what is that like after the
show because it feels like a fraternity
or a sorority
it's definitely a fraternity sorority
100 yeah like
i've never been a part of one but that's
that that's what this is like which
i am a part of this one i mean i think
i'm part of an amazing one which is
pretty cool to say
i know one of my uh guys one of my
cast mates from our season we're moving
in together by the roommates
oh that's cute it's cute right
yeah so that came from the show that's
pretty cool and i talk to all the guys
all the time i mean
i am pretty business oriented and so
therefore a lot of the guys from the
show are as well
and i help them with their business
ventures they help me with my business
ventures
that's great it's like a bunch of it's a
friend
yeah but that's nice it's almost like
collaboration in a lot of ways
with people that you have such a shared
unique experience that other people
don't have
um what about the fans the audience
because
uh i have friends that are you know very
die-hard of this
franchise and they're a certain type of
person uh
any any notable like interactions with
fans that you've had over the last
couple years
i've had oh man so many interactions i
love about station fans
i'm sure it's a wild spectrum of all
different types of interactions
you get on the head with that one it is
definitely a spectrum some things i
would tell my mom some things i won't
tell them
yeah okay the coolest thing that
happened was i was at a uh
i was at a post malone concert in dallas
and
i want to say the coolest but the most
touching moment a lady came up to me she
uh
she was crying and i'm like why are you
crying for me
but she she was crying and
her man was right there too he got
emotional and she was telling me that
while she was in the hospital battling
chemo she was watching me on tv and
just my my smile and
radiated through her it made her feel
good wow
i almost started crying
yo you got me you know you're choking me
up right here so that was
probably the most touching moment that
i've had yeah what uh
what a sweetly sensitive moment in the
middle of a post malone
concert it was an intermission time
frame
yeah yeah oh that's really cute um okay
we're going to take a quick break when
we get back i want to talk a lot about
the the new book making the love you
want
and uh how this came to be i mean it
seems like a very natural
progression for you but uh i i need to
know how to make the love i want so
we'll be right back with more not too
[Music]
deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things
a big thank you for listening to the
podcast
uh if you're a regular listener if this
is your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here
in this not too deep world we've built
and you'd like to leave us a review that
would be
so wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little
review comment how are you feeling good
bad otherwise
maybe just good or otherwise would be
appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
okay mike let's talk about making the
love you want this is your new book
that is very very exciting how did this
come
well about i so there's something that i
do i got to let out some energy of joy
yes okay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's all the energy around this book
right now yes
that's amazing it's like um
it's not exactly a memoir right it's
kind it's it's
memoir mixed with actual practical
advice for finding the love that you
want
correct yeah i'm too young memoir right
not necessarily well i
hopefully have a good four more
lifespans to go you know i'm only 32
years old
i'm way too young for that i'm an alien
remember me elon musk we go way back
that's true so who knows how long that
you have to go
exactly but making the love you want you
know comes out october 2nd world smile
day
it's the i would say the spine of the
book
is about me correctly but then the the
meat and potatoes of the book
are not about me the meat potatoes of
the book are
just literature that i wrote in regards
to how to find the love that you want
which is how
which translate directly to the success
that you want out of life
the success that you want within
yourself the confidence that you want
within yourself
the grace that you need
uh the acceptance that you need
the truth that you need right and when i
say truth
acceptance uh grace those things can be
within self
or for other people around you and
within the book it talks about
uh oh i give mantras
that i personally use every single day
in the mirror i have a monthly
blackboard
i have exercises within the book that i
personally have gone through
struggles i used to have a when i was
19 years old um i had something i guess
you would call it this
dissociative state okay and
i didn't know what was going on with me
i just know i stopped going to work i
had a girlfriend at the time i stopped
calling her
i moved back to my mom's place and just
stayed in the bed every single day
and i went to the hospital my mom made
me go to the hospital
and the doctors weren't necessarily sure
they couldn't you know they gave me a
cat scan
they put all these wires to my head and
quite honestly they were unsure of what
the issue was with me
wow they found out that i was a
dissociative state
of mind that i was in i didn't snap out
of it
for a while um i just was
i felt like i was a vegetable right i
was just wow in the bed
every single day all i kept saying was
my social security number because i
didn't want to forget my social
right i couldn't think of nothing else i
was
completely lost to life or whatever
and some of the tools that i used to get
through that experience
and other experiences are in the book
but i learned
at that moment in time in life when i
finally snapped out of it was simply
that i learned from me
that i can't be stagnant and what i had
going on in my
life at the time i felt it out as if i
was being stagnant
i wasn't progressing in life and so
something that individually for me
if i feel like i'm not progressing in
life i do become extremely depressed
and run down and just
don't want to be a part of life anymore
and so
i know that and i've had friends that
have committed suicide and i know that
i myself have thought of
crazy things uh that are going through
my head when i've had my depression
states of moments
and so i wrote this book to be a
solution to a problem that so many
people face
i think every single person in the
entire world will go through if they
haven't already gone through something
that is challenging you know mentally
challenged for them
especially right now yeah oh definitely
so can we we're in a
a crazy pandemic from social injustice
to
the country itself when it comes to
coronavirus and
like right now i can't imagine being in
an abusive household
and i can't leave that person right now
right right yeah so i think
well obviously this book won't be able
to physically help you in that regard
you need to leave the house situation
but this book definitely can
help free your mind mentally in that
situation right and so this book is for
all people that have been through
something and or are in a great
track right now but if you ever fall
back which i personally do all the time
i think
we all do it's human yeah yeah it's
human nature so therefore this book has
the tools
to get you right back to where you work
that's great i think
uh just having a guide you know
is the first step to wanting to help
yourself and
you can take it or leave it and use it
at the right moment like what happened
with you
finding the right moment to like pull
yourself out of everything
how long have you been working on this
book because it feels like
this is kind of something since you're
19 years old has been in your brain
no definitely so well the experiences
that i've gone through within this book
started
five years old wow talk about it it goes
throughout
but i would say prior to in 2017
i wanted to in 2017 three things happen
to people that i care and love about and
care and love
and i was quite honestly to be
transparent i was tired of the [ __ ]
i call it out i was like yo i need
to figure out a solution to this growing
problem of
mental illness and so 2017 i decided to
create media that would
disturb the current media that we see
every day now which is and i saw a
picture it was a girl
maybe 10 years old she had a vogue
magazine and she had some scissors
and she was hunched over like this and
she was like cutting her stomach right
uh like i was just tired of the [ __ ]
and so
back in 2017 that's when i had to start
this journey of creating
uh alternate media that was like baby
you can you can
look the way you look and you're
perfectly fine or my my brother my
homeboy like
you could have you could have a felony
you could have done something stupid now
you could
bounce back off of that right mm-hmm so
i've been working on that ever since no
one knows about that but coming off the
show
i mean now everyone knows about it for
awful surprise
but coming off the show all the dms that
i got i was just
flooded with dms and i like to respond
to people i can't respond to everybody
but i like to respond to people and
quite honestly the dm just continued to
flow
and after i would you know shut off my
phone or whatever my
my mind kept going and i would continue
to write
that just day after day turned into an
entire book
wow how cool and also a great
idea to disrupt this obviously
very overwhelmingly negative media with
just kind of like radical acceptance
of yourself uh which is very very cool
and it does
feel like this book and correct me if
i'm wrong
is for like every age group and every
gender and isn't targeted specifically
towards like
single women in their 20s or something
like that thank you so
much for saying that
you get a virtual high five i have
people that know me from the
bachelorette know that my
fan base is all women right
but my book this is a black dude that's
writing a book right i'm a man that's
right
so therefore i'm also targeting my
homeboys that want to read the book as
well
yeah so i have examples of ellen
degeneres who's a part of the lgbt
community right
or i have examples of nipsey hustle
who's a rapper and someone that i admire
look up to mac miller in my book
but then i also have mathematicians in
my book
i also have uh i talk about bell hooks
in my book so i mean
we speak gen sincere know we speak about
so many different things within this
book and i want to be able to touch
everyone not just
single women yeah right yeah yeah i want
like if your brother
is going through some [ __ ] passing my
book
yeah like this book is for i mean this
book has helped me
like literally uh when i i got called
the n word the other day
and it really pissed me off because
it happened quite a bit this day more
than most days like i get called
names every day but this day was a
little bit more than most and so i
went back to passage that i said in my
book and i just
you know tweeted it out or whatever and
just helped me out for the situation i
was going through
uh so this book is definitely not just
for single women this book is for
everyone you could be my mom she's a
married woman with two children
she's gonna be obviously she's gonna
read a book but like
so she your mom at this moment your mom
hasn't read the book yet
no which oh is that gonna be a big deal
yeah cause i talk about some things that
my mom
my grandma might not want to feel happy
about
what i've done i mean at this point
i feel like they have to be they just
know that you're gonna do what you're
gonna do
and they have to be okay with it sure
i mean i got tattoos on my arm and stuff
my mom was not happy about that
i'm like i'm gonna be a great individual
a wonderful
society and i don't want to be i want to
be a barren
you know i want to divulge from the norm
and so
you could be a tatted up person that
has done one or two illegal things in
their life that people will read about
in the book you know
still be a wonderful great society a
great person in society
right so when she reads this stuff
she'll be uh yeah at this point
i i doubt that they seem very surprised
by
what you're doing um i will ask this
red turtleneck is
this the stamp is this the this is the
look
uh how do we how do we decide on the red
turtleneck look
so i am a big big fan it's very catching
to the eye
um see that's that interesting point
right there
right interesting mike
oh it's great you look fun you look like
you're having a great time you look very
like uh someone trustworthy
good i'm glad i go i think i am pretty
trustworthy but i'm glad that wasn't
i wasn't going for it trustworthy
my my stylish has hooked me up and i
like the outfit
i think it's great it's very iconic it's
very memorable for everyone
well steve jobs wears a black turtleneck
so that's i i
i didn't know if there was a little
homage there or whatever
i mean two geniuses uh
the with the way that the world has been
the last few months
everything's upside down and turned
around are there plans for a book tour
or are there like kind of creative ideas
being floated around
their creative ideas being floated
around right now okay i
i want to see every single person that
reads this book
yeah and i mean that i want to be able
to see
every single person that reads this book
if i can't see you in person
i want to see like i'm looking at you
right now grace and i want to have i'm
considering
having a virtual book tour like a 101
and also like a general admission type
thing so oh that's cool
but then also i just want to see and hug
everybody i'm
yeah over your person you know if you
don't want to hug i ain't gonna hug you
but for those that would like to hug i
would like a hug
so i want to be i would love it if we
were able to
yeah well knock on wood um and i
i think even the virtual stuff people
would be super
excited about uh that said pandemic and
everything
uh you on a personal level uh how has
this
affected you learn anything about
yourself i've learned that i'm very bad
at cleaning
my own home and it's not like something
i can learn
it turns out i just don't have like the
gene in me that lets me clean
i don't got it uh have you learned
anything about yourself
in the the last few months and coming to
the
cleaning i legit all the time i'm like
if i have if i order ubereats or
something and i'll i'll get down with
the rapper i'll just literally be on my
couch and i'll just throw it
i'll i'll pick it up later when i get
out yeah
there you go i've picked up cycling
oh that's cool oh also aren't you train
uh training for a half marathon
yeah i'm training for a half marathon
right now how's that going
oh [ __ ] oh yeah especially the
the temperature yeah have you ever
have you ever run a half marathon before
no
never never in my life my homeboy conor
he's he like signed me up for it which
i'm glad he did because if he would have
just continued like hey you should do
this i wouldn't
no i'm not doing that yeah but then he
like he signed me up for it
and then run dallas they like put me on
like
they put my face all over their campaign
my legs were but now i do like five six
miles so that's good
there you go working at it so i would
just say i've been
it's been five months since you know
covet really
five six months yeah so at first i've
gone through my weights at first it was
like
i'm just going to eat oreos and uh-huh
a bottle of wine every night and then
after a while i was like look i need to
get
i need to get a routine going because
this not having a routine crap
is is i become annoying
irritable grouchy like
and then i'm gaining weight and so once
i started to realize
i'm gonna make this the new norm because
it seems like it's the new norm
life started getting back to better oh
that yeah
i think the getting admitting that you
need a routine
and then starting to develop one makes a
big difference
um in terms of you now are roommates
with
another bachelor nation person
you guys are all in each other's social
media
all the time do you have like a secret
code
of conduct between all of you of like
what you post about each other
that's such a good question like the
homie connor
i just because i yeah i wonder if
there's like an unwritten rule
list somewhere for you guys there needs
to be because
my homie connor he had recorded
something before
and he asked me a question i'm like bro
i'm not talking to you about it because
like this is going to be everywhere hell
no i'm not about to do that
he thought he could like sweet talk we
were like be charismatic right now bro
it ain't happening
i'm not i'm not talking right like i'm
like you already know the answer we
talked about it off camera
i'm not going to talk about something
with you
rather than talk to it with anyone else
like no
so i would say this the way that i was
on tv the exact same way i am in real
life
i'll just call you out like [ __ ] no yeah
also that bodes well for the living
situation i feel like
you guys are uh you have huge potential
to prank each other
constantly no that's gonna happen oh
that should be
really fun um
also in terms of reality tv are there
any other reality shows that you would
go on or participate in
i really don't watch much tv i know that
you are in love with real housewives
new jersey right uh all of them big fan
of all of them
yeah melissa too that's what we were
just catching up before you got here
about real housewives
but um right quick about you right
i mean i would go on like if they had
fear factor if they brought that back i
would do that
ah i could see that for sure i would
love to do that
i'm not trying to like sign up to eat
balls but
i would do a factor which is essentially
what you're doing if you sign up for
fear factor
i feel like that has to be in their
waiver that you're okay eating
some animals testicles at some point um
i would do like survivor
[Music]
or if uh no i'm not going to say that
one that one i'm not going to bring up
okay never mind no follow-up questions
there
perfect uh would you ever do like
amazing race or anything like that
i would do that 100. who would you have
as your partner
who that's a good question
i haven't i haven't found the person
because they have to be
extremely intelligent and extremely like
positive yeah page like patience is
major yeah they can't be like some
negative nasty i can't deal with that
all right like got it i don't know it's
a good question that's a real good
question
think on it think on it okay we're going
to take one last break we have a bunch
of twitter questions for you when we get
back so we'll be right back with more
not too deep
[Music]
all right mike we're back before we get
into these twitter questions i'm going
to ask you the two
questions i ask every single guest that
is on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most
like to throw cold spaghetti at
yeah donald trump yeah yeah
i know there's no real other answer
these days
[Laughter]
i would love to see that happen too i
think that'd be really good promo for
your book
and i think you would uh help a lot of
people out
uh okay the other question i ask every
single guest is to tell us
your worst pants [ __ ] story or uh
like bathroom close call
but you can only use uh you can only use
three words
or three small phrases or like some
combination
so for example mine is
college jogging front lawn
okay it just happened the other day oh
oh no
okay like two weeks ago
mine would be
texas summer heat oh no
outside ran out of gas
i don't know if ran out of gas is a
metaphor or not but
uh no follow-up questions there okay
uh we have some twitter questions for
you our
first one melissa wants to know does
your back
still hurt from carrying the season
wow and i like i like that tweet very
much because yeah
that resonates wow wow wow
did you work out back today yeah it's
back day
uh i do like because you guys are all
friends now for the most part where
you're
all like you know on good terms with
each other when you guys left the show
were you all on good terms or was it
kind of all over the place
um when we as immediately after leaving
the show
i was pretty much cool with everybody
except for like two people
right okay so i have no i don't have no
black
i still don't have bad blood with nobody
that's great i mean
that's why your shoulders and back must
be so tired from carrying everyone
uh okay a lot of people are asking
about the demi lovato situation
what about uh i have no i have no
knowledge of that is this a thing or is
this a mysterious
if we're gonna speak of her i would say
congratulations to her
okay yeah okay we'll leave it at that
a favorite restaurant in san antonio
they got some really good margaritas
alone okay
and elmer they got two el mirasores but
i like the og original
okay okay once restaurants
they're oh my god they uh they got these
they got this mole
chocolate is so good yeah you look like
you went to a different place in your
head
uh okay someone wants to know what was
it like trying to date and socialize
after the bachelorette i imagine there's
like a little bit of a
wonky period right after getting used to
people watching you date on television
i mean again to me like if i were to ask
a lady on a date
i'm i'm treating you
with everything i'm giving you i'm
treating you like you know gold right
i don't i might tell you i might say
this one time i might say
hey those people those people over there
are taking pictures of us okay but
that's
it like and i'll write back to you
to me i mean i'm just a human right i'm
the same guy
yeah you you can't help the situation
that you're in at this point
uh but it also must be do you ever get
mistaken
for other people um jake from state farm
is that true really
oh that's incredible
that's very very funny did people try
and take a photo with you
um
no in person normally in person like
after a while they'll figure it out
unless i'm not smiling the way that i
can walk around in person
he's like if i got a do-rag on and i'm
not smiling at all
no one knows no one recognizes me but
when i open my mouth
and start smiling it's a different story
wow so you must be
able to go anywhere with this mask
situation
uh okay molly wants to know weirdest
behind the scenes moment that didn't air
on the bachelorette
freaking half the guys running around
naked like
like bro like some of these dudes be
suspect
what's up little wiggly
oh thing because i you guys are all just
like living on top of each other the
whole time so you get to see how people
really are oh that's very funny a true
fraternity
uh okay someone wants to know
if uh he was stuck on a deserted island
with three other people
from the bachelor franchise who would
they be and why
demi burnett because she is freaking
hilarious
okay yeah he's gonna be my entertainment
she's gonna be my tv
um like she's just freaking hilarious
then i would say
i would say
i'm not gonna say another girl um
i would say clay harbor because he's
like this ex-nfl player
all he wants to do is work out okay he
would keep me in shape
okay and then i would i would then i
would say dylan i would say dylan barber
because he's like my little brother he's
he's a little [ __ ] that is funny
but also incredibly intelligent and our
conversations are great
oh that's sweet i mean that rounds out
everyone so
all of your needs are met on this island
yeah
yeah um okay
last question kendall says uh how do i
make sure
i'm emotionally available to start
dating again after ending a long-term
relationship
i would i would have to ask i want
follow-up questions yeah
like well i think this could speak a
little bit to
your book right that you're teaching
people to find like the power in
themselves and find like the love for
themselves
and i feel like if people are in a long
term relationship a lot of their
identity gets you know connected to that
relationship
so when you're out there yeah when
people say
uh people feel like they lost their they
lost them
they lost themselves they lost their
identity they lost
just oneself within being in a
relationship
and that's why again it goes back to
seriously i i'm gonna get this
tatted on me like you can never make
anyone else happy until you make
yourself happy right
so to the viewer the twitter
viewer that asked that question i would
definitely say
just you will know once you are
completely
satisfied in your life without anybody
else
you're just you're just happy you're
content you're satisfied with what you
have going on right now
i think that's great yeah once you feel
totally okay by yourself that's usually
a good sign that you can add someone
else into the mix with you
that is true but then also and this is
my comical side
but also very serious side the issue
with being single for too long
is like you get stuck in your ways oh
true
mm-hmm like you can get stuck in your
ways and so just be cognizant of that as
well
i think that's great is there one major
thing you want people to take away
from your book when they read it
that how do i pronounce your last name
helbig
so you're a grace [ __ ] hell
[ __ ] and i want you to say it with your
chest poked out
i want everybody to read my book to say
it and mean it and own it and know it
wow i felt that that was very powerful
my book is extremely powerful oh that's
so wonderful well
mike we've reached the end of the
podcast but before we wrap everything up
uh i know this is so wonderful and i
appreciate and i feel like i've learned
so much
um usually when we do the podcast in
person we have a poor a little gift
for our guests for making time for us
and uh because we're doing it
digitally we have a virtual gift for you
we have a personalized fortune cookie
from us to you i did find it okay okay
let's see what your what your future
holds
i'm just smiling already we predict we
predict great success for your book
make the love you want however at least
two percent of those people will only
read the title
and mistake it has a book about baking
cookies when you're sad
yeah so be careful be careful
we know if i do a virtual book tour i
should definitely have some cookies
right because i need parts of the book
there you go
um now mike where can people
get your book uh where can they find you
on social media if they don't already
know everything that you're up to
yes so you go to social media my ig is
mike underscore
johnson my website is where you can
pre-order the book
mikejohnsonsmile.com if you don't
necessarily want to
you're on easy if you want to get the
book you can go to my website and just
sign up for the newsletters
tomorrow our newsletters start once a
week i'm going to be sending out
personal newsletter and also a mantra
so therefore it you know builds that
anticipation up
and facebook don't find me on there i
don't know how people find me
i'm like no and then twitter
mike johnson one underscore
yes mike underscore johnson
mikejohnsonsmile.com
awesome awesome awesome go get this book
go change your life
go get yourself pumped you are
[ __ ]
filling your name there mike thank you
so much for being here for this episode
of not too deep this was so wonderful
and we'll see you guys next time goodbye
thank you
sweet too deep too deep too
deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis post
production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music